مشاجره الكرام المعاناه الانسانيه هي نتاج
الاول لاي ميزان يشمل المناطق المدنيه كما
هو الحال في اوكرانيا ولذا نجلس حصريا
الان مع ضيفتنا عبر الاثير من كييف
الدبلوماسيه الكنديه دنيس براون المنسق
الانساني الاممي المقيمه في اوكرانيا
والمسؤوله الامميه الاولى في مواجهه
التحديات الانسانيه المتصاعده في حرب لا
تعرف الهوادر
المنسقه الانسانيه المقيمه للامم المتحده
في اوكرانيا مرحبا بك الى قناه العربيه
والحدث شكرا اود ان اسالك اولا ان كنتم
تتوقعون المزيد من هجمات الروسيه المركزه
في هذه المناسبه والاهم انت شعب اوكرانيا
كيف تتخذون الاجراءات الاضافيه في هذه
المناسبه لن اتكهن
حول ما قد او قد لا يحصل فيما يخص الهجمات
ولكن لاحظنا
زياده في الضربات
الجويه وهجمات الصواريخ خاصه في الجانب
الشرقي نحن نتخذ اجراءات الاحترازيه
اليوميه
ونتبع توجيهات الحكومه حرفيا فاذا ما اطلق
الصفات الانذار نذهب الى الملجا ونبقى
هناك ونقيد حركتنا قدر الامكان
يعني نهايتي سبتمبر 20
و2200 الف اوكرانيا سجلوا لي الحمايه
المؤقته في اوروبا وسته الف شخص اخر
نازحون داخليا وحوالي 18 مليون اوكراني
بحاجه الى المساعدات الانسانيه
حوالي اربعون بالمئه من سكان اوكرانيا
بصفتك المنسقه الانسانيه والمسؤوله
الانسانيه على الارض في اوكرانيا كيف
تقومين انت وفريقك او تتاقلمونا مع هذه
التحديات الانسانيه الضخمه انها بالفعل لا
كبيره جدا وهي ثاني اكبر استجابه انسان
يقمن بها في تاريخ الامم المتحده
هنالك احتياجات جديده تقريبا في كل يوم
بعد عندما كنا قصف جوي سواء كانت المنازل
او المدارس او العيادات الطبيه فان
الارواح تزهق والعائله تمزق وهي ازمه
تتطور في كل يوم ايضا وهي ليست بالشيء
الثابت ولا يوجد شيء واحد نستجيب له الوضع
على الخطوط من الجبهات احيانا الصعبه جدا
ان نصفه بكلمه واحده صادم ومروع
هنالك احتياجات كثيره جدا حول زياده هنالك
نوع من التردد صحيح الاحتياجات العالميه
كبيره جدا ومشاهدناهم مؤخرا في تركيا
وسوريا مع الهزه الارضيه وكذلك فلسطين
وازمات الاخرى
ولكننا متفائلون وانا متفائله من ان مستوى
الاستجابه التي حصل عام 2022
ام بين الدول الاعضاء وحتى المنظمات سوف
يستمر في 20 23
مع استمرار الحرب هذه الازمه تستمر وتتعمق
ونحن دائما
بحاجه لاخذ نظر الاعتبار لكل اضرار على
البنى التحتيه وعلى مدنيين فانا سنستمر
وكلنا سنستمر ولهم متحده ايضا ستستمر
بالتحدث عن شعبي اوكرانيا
واثار هذه الحرب على حياتهم وعلى مستقبلهم
صندوق النقد الدولي يقدر بان
اوكرانيا قد تتطلبوا بي
دعم ما ليصل الى اربعين مليار دولار هل
تعتقدير لابن هذا التوقع واقعي وهل يمكن
تحقيقه لن نتكهنات فيما يخص اجمالي المبلغ
المطلوب ولكن ما استطيع ان اقوله هو ما
اشهده على الارض وانا شاهد لما يجري كل
الخطوط الاماميه وكل
ما تدمر من المنازل
والعياداتي وحتى الحقول الالغام التي يمكن
استغلالها قبل المزارعين
فمهما كانت طلب النهائي
فسيكون كبيرا جدا وتكلفه هذه الحربه مره
اخرى على حياه الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
تتجاوز اي رقم او اي مبلغ
ملايين وتسعمائه الفا اوكراني ساعود الى
اللجوء في الاتحاد الاوروبي وتم تلقيهم
بحفاوه الصدر
حتى المسؤول الاوروبيه قال اذا ما استمر
اللاجئون بالتدفقيه فهل تتوقعين بان هذا
الترحيب الاوروبي وخاصه في بعض دول شرق
اوروبا ان يستمر بهذه الحفاوه
مره اخرى لنا تكهن
وبشكل السياسه المستقبل النفاق كله من
غادر اوكرانيا بسبب الحرب تم استقبالهم في
دول الجوار وحصلوا على تعميق بال الحكومات
والمجتمع المدني والمفوضيه العليا للاجئين
لا اعتقد بانه سيكون هناك اي تغيير في هذا
الاتجاه
اخر التقديرات المتحده تشير الى وجود اكثر
من 7000 مدنيين قتلوا في اوكرانيا خلال
العام الماضي واثني عشر الفا مصابا
وحلب التاكيد
تقدير متواضع انت هناك على الارض
كيف يتاقلم ويتكيف والشعب الاوكراني مع
هذه الخساره المستمره ولا توجد اي نهايه
في المنظور القريب كل هذه المجتمعات او
انا بينهم
مصدومنا جدا نحن بعزيمه مرونه الشعب
الاوكراني الذين يعيشون
[موسيقى]
ضربات جويه يوميه وحتى في كل ساعه وياخذون
اغلب اوقاتهم في الملاجئ هم يتكيفون ولكن
ما هم بحاجه اليه مجلس استمرار بالتكيف
والتاقلم هو دعمنا سواء الدول الاعضاء
والمجتمع المدني والمنظمات واعتقد باننا
اجتمعنا خلال عام 2022 على الاقل عبر
المتحده سوف نستمر بتواجدنا هنا
وهل مساعدات الانسانيه تصل الى السكان
خارج المناطقه السيطره لحكومه الاوكرانيه
وفي الخطوط الاماميه وهذا مهم جدا
الخطوط الاماميه نعم
نحن نصل الى ما يقول من ثلاثه كلمه من
الخطوط الاماميه التي تقدم مساعداتي الى
السكان هناك ولكن للاسف لم نتمكن من تجاوز
الخطوط الاماميه
فانا اتطلب ضمانه امنيه لكي تتجاوزوا
فريقنا هذه الخطوط وهي خطوط نشيطه
وللاسف
احصل عليها من الاوكرانيين عندما اطلبها
رسميا ولكن الى الان لم استقبلها من جانب
روسيا ولكننا سنستمر بالعمل على ذلك وهذا
واجبنا ومسؤوليتنا لتوفير المساعدات
للاوكرانيين اينما كانوا على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
وكاله انسانيه تعمل في اوكرانيا لتلبيه
احتياجات الشعب الاوكراني انت
والامم المتحده وفريقك هل تنسقون معهم
جميعا
فانا مسؤوله عن الاستجابه الانسانيه سواء
كانت المنظمات غير الحكوميه والوطنيه وحتى
الوكاله الاماميه هذا سبب وجودي هنا وكلنا
نسعى لتحقيق هدف واحد وهو حمايه ودعم شعبي
اوكرانيا الذين تاثرت حياتهم بالحرب
في ديسمبر خاصه 20 مليون دولار
من صندوق الدعم
الانسان الاوكرانيه الى 14
غير حكوميه وهم شركائهم المتحده والذين
لديهم اكثر من
المنظمات فيها متطوعين لانها قلت بان
الوضع صعب جدا خاصه
لاجراءات الاداريه او البيروقراطيه هل
نجحت في جهودك انت محقق تماما
ما كان ممكن لمئاتي
من منظمه تطوعيه للوصول الى اهداء التمويل
فقدمنا نموذجا سمحنا لهم بالحصول عليها
عبر الشراكات الوطنيه والدوليه ديسمبر
وكنا بحاجه الى الوقت للتعرف على مدى
نجاحها انا متفائله جدا وهذا عنصر سيقربنا
معا
اقصد في الهيكليه لسان العالميه والطوعين
المحليين الذين يعملون يوميا في الخطوط
الاماميه وهذا يمكن ان يصبح نموذجا
نستخدمه في الاستجابات الانسانيه الاخرى
فانا متفائله جدا
السؤال الاخير
حول
الدراما النفسيه التي يتعرض لها الشعب
هذه اولويه قصوى للحكومه والرئيس الوزراء
وزير الصحه
والسيدطنه هذا العمل ام منظمه الصحه
العالميه التخيل لو كنت في منزلك
وتشهد ضربات او قصف جوي مستمر او لا قدر
الله اذا ما ضرب صاروخ مبناكما
في حيك اكبر تخوفنا مع اطفالي اوكرانيا
الذين يعيشون كل هذه الصدمات ونقدم لهم
الدعم في منازلهم وخارجها وفي المدارس من
اجل ضمان
قدراتنا بشكل ما او قدرتهم على التكيف
معهد صدمات الكبيره جدا
هذه هي اول صدمه النفسيه الاجتماعيه بدايه
ازمه جديده في اوكرانيا
ولكننا سنتعامل معها الى جانب الاوكرانيين
الملصق الانسانيه المقيمه للامم المتحده
في اوكرانيا نشكرك على هذه المقابله
ونشكرك على وقتك ونتمنى لك واثره
في كل العام الخير تقومين شكرا جزيلا